the high-stakes NATO summit is just
getting underway with President Trump
slamming US allies in the military
alliance the president arrived at NATO
headquarters in Belgium just minutes ago
after telling its secretary-general that
several NATO partners are not spending
enough on defense he also called Germany
captive to Russia because of a plan to
build a natural gas pipeline between the
two countries this meeting begins mr.
Trump's four-city European trip that
will end with his highly anticipated
summit with Russian President Vladimir
Putin weisia Jang is traveling with the
president in Brussels we a good morning
good morning John president Trump set
the tone for the summit during that
meeting with the secretary-general
typically leaders hash out their
conflicts in private but their tense
exchange unfolded as the cameras were
rolling and now there is no question
just how hard the president plans to
press NATO allies over money
moments after posing for a pleasant
photo-op president Trump lectured NATO
secretary-general yawn stone Berg
accusing other NATO members of not
paying their fair share of defense
spending the United States does pay a
higher percentage of its GDP toward
defence than any other NATO member about
twice as much as France and roughly
three times more than Germany in 2014
NATO countries set a goal to contribute
2% by 2024 but the president interpreted
that as a formal commitment president
Trump also singled out Germany for
supporting gas deals with Moscow since
one of NATO's main objectives is to stop
Russian aggression
person you want protection against or
from the group that you want detection
because to understand when we start
together also in dealing with Russia we
are stronger I think what we have seen
is no you just make it Russia richer
well dealing with Russia making Russia
richer secretary Stoltenberg
acknowledged some NATO members agree
with the president's point but said it
shouldn't divide the Alliance later
today president Trump will meet with
French president Emmanuel macron and
German Chancellor Angela Merkel who
responded a short time ago saying she is
expecting controversial discussions
during this summit US allies are also
wary of the president's warm embrace of
Vladimir Putin especially since their
one-on-one summit in Helsinki is just
days away Alex
lots to talk about there we Jiang in
Brussels thinks we job